topic is what would you give up for the
right guy and Men what would you expect
the right girl to give up for you
so
um what do you give up in a relationship
well I have a lot to give so as a lot to
sacrifice because I'm a personal faith I
do follow Traditional Values of Faith so
there's a lot of me on the line
for me to give up and
um yeah it's uh it's obviously the
sexual side so I uh you know in
Christian faith you you wait until
marriage Okay so
I'm willing to wait for that man that
high value man yeah and that's a lot to
give up okay so you would give up
waiting for marriage
or like not give um you would like have
him wait
oh I wouldn't give that oh okay I
understood this right yeah yeah so I'm
saying yeah
no no I would never give up this for any
high value man waiting till marriage
yeah okay are you a virgin
yeah oh really yeah I never thought I
would disclose this so publicly but yeah
oh okay okay so you want to wait until
you're married yeah okay
um would you give up let's say like
social media
yeah that wouldn't be a problem yeah I
would give up
all right hold on
that's actually really good I think I
think in that culture is that's what
they have to do so I think when she has
to
um do certain things that they have to
give up social media they can't present
themselves in certain ways so I think
when you say would you give up a
high-end man
then we have to look at perspectively
above board as how would we do that of
women of different cultures so her
culture they wouldn't be able to do that
well you guys don't have social media no
I'm on social media but uh yeah I grew
up in a Sudanese Arabic culture which is
very strict however I lived most of my
life in Germany I live here and I'm very
modern society so I did get influence
from here as well not just from my
background but
um in terms of I think it's not the it's
high value Menace we were speaking about
this early apparel and I would love to
have your perspective as well as how do
you define a high value when and how do
you define a modern woman because the
way I Define a high value men may be
very different than you define it and
then they Define it so the way I Define
a high value men is somebody who is
Faith driven who is a respectable who's
got um yeah he's got Integrity so it's
it values but it's also he definitely
has to have a job for sure make money
but there's other aspects I look for and
have element for me to give up something
anything what does he bring to to the
table as well well so I would Define
high value men as the men that women
pick
so like the men that women routinely go
after and choose and Kevin Samuels
actually is the one who coined that term
so he he laid it out
um it's 10K per month he has to have had
that for three to five years
um other men must accept him as high
value he has to have a network of high
value men he has to be LinkedIn
visibility level and he must be useful
to others in the group
so that's the definition yeah yeah
that's what we have to take into account
different cultures different people's
Lifestyles
his is his lifestyle that's not my
lifestyle that's not her lifestyle
that's not his or his or different
cultures so we can have a statistic that
says that but you can't truly say that
and I think we need to be open when we
ask that question because we live in a
very diverse world right now I can't
truly say that um because women only
swipe right five percent of the time on
dating apps and we typically pick the
same men
um so I would go on a date in up and I
would never pick my mother enough I mean
if you if you even at a bar you see
women approach or like go after the same
type of guys
how would you know that initially the
average woman yeah no no no I don't know
how would you know that list you asked
that person that was going into the bar
what type of guy are you approached to
you can watch you can see who they go
after and the most statistics come from
um so where where do my Stats come from
there's different studies that talk
about this it's pretty cut and dry on
like Tinder Bumble like there's so many
dating and even and even if you wait
wait I'm trying to answer your question
so and even if you go off of dating apps
like I do it on the show where we could
go through you guys one by one and put
out what you want in a guy and it's
usually less than 20 percent of men I
think that's a human that I want in a
guy X Y inside is no I'm saying in
general in general that's I think that
is the key Point well the average is
that your average but that's why she
says most people are average okay well
then I probably maybe because I've
looked at it
people would give up
um and I think it's subjective so how
would we How would we look at us and add
an average woman what would you say is
an average woman then
average to me is going to be different
to what Alex thinks is average to what
Gary fix is everything
like statistically there is an average
or like in general I get that but who
says who sets the statistics
what Paul will say like from the dating
apps which part are you asking about the
women are you asking about the heights I
looked at statistically a thousand men
and they said to me
this is what they would prefer you're
going to prefer my report are you gonna
prefer somebody that's going to say to
you well you know what this is what I've
done and this is what I've looked at and
this is what I found
um I would probably go buy experience
and studies which are usually pretty
similar like if I put up lizzo most guys
will probably pass
um
yes yeah yeah over
oversized women are coming back right
now and I I probably for women to who
well from mine maybe not you but for a
lot of men she does well we're sat here
laughing and we're sat here laughing and
like
do you know the percentage of the
population about how many women are
oversized too many do you know too many
it's like there's more well listen I
work in medicine and weight and stuff
and I see a lot more oversized women and
they're trying and if you see the
adverts that we see on TV from marks and
Spencer Tesco's a lot of them
that doesn't mean that they're the women
that Mendes either that doesn't okay so
are you guys sat here underway with a
six AB
s that's not a discussion here well
that's what I'm asking you so much
because what's your point stick to the
facts because if you're commenting on
oversized women you're trying to decide
for men what they like and you're not
really in a position to do that I'm
trying to not being a man that shoot
they shouldn't be
um
you don't think you
should discriminate in who you date
I don't think you should discriminate
against anybody yeah but so so you want
you want to you want a short broke guy
five five choose okay unemployed why I
do there's some crackheads down the
street I can set you up with should I
tell you okay
I'm dead serious but let me tell you I
make my choices so I decide to choose
who I want today because I think you
decide you want to choose you want to
date you and you do right it doesn't
matter what it bases on it's based on
what I like
and we're talking a
do you think you and lizzo have an
equally attractive body
do you think you do I think I have a
better body than lizzo do you think you
and do you think you think you've
ultimately just discriminated yourself
from her
how well you just said you have a better
body yeah that's not discrimination
I don't think it takes much time when we
do when we talk about
color against white and black ice matter
do we not discriminate or do we want to
not have that conversation or does it
now suit you better because we're not
talking about size it's not healthy so
yeah it's only from that perspective
it's not just about how she looks There
Is Now They are promoting that's what
I'm trying to say that it's fine being
overweight it's healthy because it looks
good and that no it you're right it is
her choice to be overweight but it's not
a good choice it's not a good job
healthy facts the slimmest person who
you'd think would look the healthiest
could have could unhealthiest lifestyle
and she might just have a percentage of
body fat because she just eats
differently did you look at that did you
know that um as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible